well one superstar not at forest hills
novak djokovic he's barred entry into
the u.s because of course he's not
vaccinated for coven and that has the
white house struggling to explain an
apparent double standard as migrants
walk across the southern border
vaccinated status unchecked fox's peter
ducey brought that up at the white house
yesterday with the briefing watch
how come migrants are allowed to come
into this country unvaccinated but
world-class tennis players are not the
u.s government also does not comment on
medical information of individual
travelers this is a cdc
requirement for foreign nationals this
is something that they decide
let's bring in outkick founder clay
travis clay you heard the the sound by
there from the white house clearly they
don't have an answer on this we know
that the illegal immigrants are walking
across the border that's the way it is
they're also being bussed and planed
into several cities around the country
vaccination status unclear and if you
can believe it they're also welcome to
go to the u.s open if they want to
uh yes first fantastic question i've
been asking this for a while and i don't
know what the legal ramifications would
be but what if novak djokovic had just
walked across our southern border with
his tennis racquet in his backpack and
hopped on one of those buses and gone up
to new york would he have been able to
play if he were able to enter into the
united states and it's patently absurd
there's no way to defend this if you are
flying into the united states and you
are a foreign national you're required
to have gotten the covet shot if you
just walk right across our southern
border there is no requirement for the
covet shot whatsoever how can you
reconcile those two disparate treatments
you can't credit to peter ducey for
asking karine jean-pierre to try to
explain it she can't i'd love to hear
somebody like joe biden try to explain
it i'm certain that he couldn't either
because let's be honest he can barely
explain anything at this point
but the fact that novak djokovic isn't
playing in this tournament right now in
the u.s open particularly because he
played last year is an absolute disgrace
to american policy and further evidence
of our failures when it comes to covin
what's interesting is that if you
buy a ticket to go to the u.s open as a
spectator you don't have to prove
vaccination status i i'm very fortunate
i get to go this year i'm excited so you
don't have to do that but you and that's
sitting in cheek to jaw with the person
next to you
um but the players themselves they don't
and i wonder if you think
you know how much longer this can go on
because you also have the situation
where other
athletes like novak djokovic kyrie
irving aaron rodgers
they are all unvaccinated and so
as the cdc's protocols change
can't the biden administration see their
way to figuring out a way to deal with
this as well
yeah dana look my argument is that
covent policy in the united states is
the biggest public policy failure in
america since the vietnam war and when
you mentioned novak yokovich when you
mention uh aaron rodgers who had a great
interview with joe rogan over the past
weekend and kyrie irving three different
athletes who all refused to get the
coven shot and i believe are going to be
proven correct in that as young and
healthy guys they looked at the data
said there's no reason for us to get
this shot stood up to the mandates of
the united states government were
willing to take the slings and arrows of
the larger cultural context when
everyone especially in the sports media
turned up on them and i believe these
guys are all going to be vindicated they
already have been based on the data and
it points to dana a larger cultural
schism here we need to end all covid
restrictions there are kids right now
going to school in philadelphia having
to wear masks this is madness there's
controversy in washington d.c over
whether unvaxed kids can even attend
school we've got kids i believe in head
start programs very young kids still
being required to wear masks there
should be zero coveted restrictions
anywhere in the country coveted shot or
not covened shot
this is madness that we still have it
yeah
it is amazing clay traps you um check
them out uh you have that great piece on
outkick.com we appreciate you being here
thank you yup thank you clay
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now